is someone um i haven't seen this
gentleman ever so if you're watching
please listen up um he
does a lowest lane impression whenever
i'm walking my dog in the park
and he screams at the top of his voice
shouting help me save me superman save
me
it was very intimidating i only took
comfort in knowing that i'm playing this
version of superman of batman excuse me
is the um that's right it's
understandable i know i got
fat man slept with superman's mom
now we know superman must find out on
some level you must know
i think so yeah super smell
it just gets better
this is possibly the greatest show i've
ever heard
having sex with someone you're normally
alone
where normal
[Music]
man of steel bonds of steel
how hard do you train and um
how hard you train
um
i'll be interested the next question was
there when you're on set you're you've
got at least sort of 12 very very
heavily set men watching you and um it's
not comfortable and and you know things
aren't happening as naturally as they
should so things are
you know there's a lot of this
and that's not comfortable either um
uh one of my kids has a question for you
which is that if you could take any of
the potions that the witcher uh has
which as as you henry cavill what would
you take would you take any of the
potions none of them no
didn't hear what i said
well yeah toxic it will kill me
so do you correct
people um i don't necessarily
i'm i am effusive about getting the uh
being being loyal to the source material
let's put it that way okay so yes yes
you do
playing a demigod informing your what
your preparation for superman
um
well i'm gonna say theseus isn't a
demigod
that's what he says on wikipedia yeah
wikipedia
using wikipedia is your source of
information
did tom cruise give you like a big
present i know he's like a big gift
giver
did he give you a present at the end of
this film uh we the the famous christmas
thing which happens every year is tom
sends a christmas cake a coconut cake
yeah coconut cake yes and so i get this
i heard about this coconut cake right
and then one day i received said coconut
cake which said happy christmas henry
from tom cruise right
which is pretty cool by the way
and i thought this is yeah no there's no
way i'm eating that it's going to be
like made of healthy stuff it's going to
be daily or whatever
yeah this is christmas i don't do
healthy at christmas yeah and eventually
a friend came around to my house and saw
the cake sitting there they said what's
that and i said oh that's a that's a
cake from tom cruise and they said i'm
sorry say that again i said that's a
that's a cake from tom cruise and they
went why aren't you eating it i said
it's probably healthy and they went cut
it open cut it open it is the most
luxurious unhealthy
cake coconut okay yeah yeah yeah and so
um i then ate the whole thing
i could change the world in some way
[Music]
that's a very good question
i don't really know
henry you're probably not going to miss
your face furniture you're not fond of
the face furniture are you oh it's not
that i'm not fond of it it's just that
you know if i'm if i'm walking past
schools people give me funny looks
it's tough to buy vans
can't give children sweeties
so what was the funniest blooper from
the mission of possible sex sex
six
six set it's a different movie
uh that that you can share you nearly
lost quite an important job absolutely
yeah i was um i was playing a game
called world of warcraft and i've heard
of all them yeah yeah and um i i missed
the call from zack snyder to tell me i
got superman but like did you hear the
phone ringing i did and you chose to
ignore it absolutely
[Music]
did you win the video game sadly no
who made a girl in your family how did
that happen brother number three and we
don't know how it happened wow i mean
amazing we're assuming it's him anyway
do they do they
love the fact and brag about the fact
that you are superman as well absolutely
yes uh and a good story my uh nephew
thomas he went to school one day and it
was you know talk about your family day
and he was telling all the school kids
that his uncle was superman
and of course the teacher then said
thomas that we don't lie in school
we don't do that i i appreciate good
storytelling yes but it's not a good
habit to get into and thomas was stood
by his guns but no no but my uncle is
superman and i swear he as i promise and
so she got upset with him uh he got in
trouble and then my sister-in-law was
pulled aside when she was picking him up
from school the teacher said look we
don't
we don't encourage our children to tell
lies in school
and i recommend that you would do the
same
and of course then she said about what
exactly
knowing that thomas is he does tell tall
tales that she was she was all in she's
like oh no not again right and then oh
uh she was saying that his uncle is
superman she went oh
i hate to tell you this it's all true
right yeah
you should speak at career day yeah
it's certainly a lot of jokes every time
i get in a plane um air hostesses would
say sort of well thank god you're here
because if anything goes wrong i'm like
you do realize i can't actually do any
of that stuff
so hopefully
hopefully nothing bad happens
there's henry back there flying he's
hanging out he's not even flying a
helicopter
henry's lucky because he can actually
fly anyways yes of course
something i found fascinating because
i'm reading your bio you met a celebrity
came to your school yeah um
russell crowe was filming proof of life
and i was an extra in the background of
the movie so this is like 10 years ago
right
goodness 11 years ago okay all right why
are you looking at me for some old
information
it was five centuries ago
[Applause]
for cardio sake what do you do for
cardio
no cardia no i run
that's the savory answer yeah so what is
the real answer you do
i think they get it
i think okay
how do you feel now do you feel that
henry isn't really able to come out
himself now my mustache bullies me
i can barely sleep at night because it
forces me to put a moustache hammock
onto it so it can sleep so i can sleep
who would have known the driver it is
the master of me right now
[Music]
lose all sense of like fear and
adrenaline for the height you start
thinking if i were to fall could i kind
of like squirrel suit with my
make it all the way to the water maybe
just like skim
you've been in superman two months
why are you the oldest uh number four
out of five so the second youngest oh
that's the worst spot to be in right
no it isn't you're not the youngest well
let's evaluate all the spots because the
youngest at least you're the youngest
you know you're the baby you've got
something kind of different
kind of have mom protecting you a little
bit but it is only so like if we were
the olympics you know the first one
would be the gold medalist the second
one will be silver the bronze and then
there's you just kind of standing off to
the side
disappointed
uh no the eldest gets the toughest game
one hundred percent because they get all
the discipline and it's the time it gets
to us we're being it's all just
free-for-all at number four you must
then get really strong and tough because
your brothers are your brothers all like
built like you are we're all we're all
of a similar side absolutely yeah but i
was i was smart i never i never picked
battles with them my oldest brother was
that one up was uh four years older than
me he was considerably larger and
incredibly strong simon um we
he was so strong that we would make fun
of him by saying hulk smash every time
he got angry
and so there are a lot of superheroes in
this family
and so that was not the guy i picked my
fight for all right
i went down
yeah bitwick kyle um who i watched a lot
of youtube videos of and he was
absolutely fantastic um he was really
informative about how to do all this
stuff and then it's just
reading the manual
um which a lot of people don't do and
they end up asking questions online and
people always respond with rtfm which is
read the manual
were the suits particularly sweaty
because there is an official remedy for
that we actually got sent official
batman v superman eau de toilette no i'm
not right i'm not sure if that's uh a
mixture of both of your mosques or one
of your i'm not sure how
did they get that from why they kept
wiping me down and wanting to that's
what it is
it's got you on the box so maybe it's
you're on the box you're around the
corner as well it's quite pungent is it
really
oh yeah that's ben
that's mostly bad stephanie